hey youtubers is Charlie so earlier this
week I asked you guys to submit all of
your arrow related questions about
season 2 Deathstroke League of Assassins
in the flash so I picked 10 of them to
answer in this video this is just the
first of many arrow q and A's this
season so get excited also heads up
because doing these bonus videos has
made it harder to do a lot of the other
videos I would normally do during the
week I also included some bits about
community and American Horror Story at
the end after the QA think of it as like
a super ketchup video but I'm also gonna
be posting a big channel update video
next week be sure to subscribe to get it
I'm gonna be changing my upload schedule
just a little bit just because the
channels starting to grows you can also
follow me on twitter at robot challenger
for a regular updates about my channel
too so Q&A time let's get going question
number one
michail pace asks who will be the first
flash villain in the most current origin
story it's sabot R that killed his
mother but surprise surprise it turns
out to be professor zoom behind it all
so professor zoom will always be the
Flash's version of the Joker you know
the most infamous villain but they'll
also have a medium bad so we'll meet
that villain first you know that'd be
level villain it'll be someone from the
rogue's gallery probably question number
2 jack gibson asks what mass do you
think is the better one from the island
or the new one I actually like the new
one best the old mask was just a piece
of cloth and I really hated the black
and yellow colors together I like that
new burnt orange steel look much better
I would have been a lot happier if they
just stuck with the classic yellow and
blue color scheme though question number
three Ignatian yokocho asks could
Oliver's father come back from the
Lazarus Pit in an episode or are you
fully convinced that he died I think
that Merlyn being Thea's father is the
only you know Empire Strikes Back father
twist that we'll be seeing this season I
always thought of Oliver's father as a
normal person who became a victim of the
shadow world you know like a normal
person who found out he was living in a
world of superheroes I think the only
character that DC would let use one of
those Lazarus pits at least the first
time is raeshell Ghul question number 4
Jesus riah's asks do you think that
arrow will talk to deathstroke about the
island yeah definitely we haven't even
gotten to the episode where slay loses
his eye and they haven't destroyed the
mirakuru yet and Oliver and Slade are
still friends on the island so Slade
will have to start blaming Oliver for
shadows death at some point so they
still need to have that falling-out on
the island and then they'll probably
address that whenever they have their
first confrontation in Starling city
question number 5
Dylan Isle asks when do you expect
to wake up from his coma short answer
during the pilot episode of the spinoff
if they had not decided to just do a
full pilot episode and a used episode 20
as a backdoor pilot like they originally
planned he probably would have woken up
during that episode in the timeline of
arrow and the flash hope I still wake up
at the same point though whenever you
know he was originally going to wake up
in that episode 20 question six
check the asks a super long question do
you think that Deathstroke is part of
the League of Assassins storyline if so
do you think they'll go the Grant
Morrison path and do a son of Batman
story twist where Deathstroke tries to
kidnap some sort of secret half-brother
of Oliver's and take over the League of
Assassins I don't think that Deathstroke
is part of the league he was already
Special Forces when he was on the island
so he was already a trained assassin and
with the mirakuru he would have just
eventually learned to control his new
abilities and I don't think they're
going to introduce any new character so
Deathstroke will probably just end up
kidnapping Felicity and trying to turn
her against Oliver remember during the
mid-season finale he said corrupt the
ones he loves and destroy those who
choose to work with him
so Slade is gonna try and corrupt
Felicity and destroy Roy and Barry too
if he you know wakes up and comes back
to the finale with flash superpowers
question number seven Daniel asks do you
think that Oliver should also get
injected with the mirakuru in my opinion
the villains are just too powerful Plus
now Roy is stronger than him no I don't
think you should get the mirakuru
one of the big aspects of Green Arrow
and Batman are that they do not have
super powers they're normal people who
are so good that they can be just as
effective as people with superpowers if
they did give him super powers it would
kind of diminish his eventual triumph
over Slade - one of the big themes of
the arrow character in the comic books
and on the show is that you don't need
superpowers to be a superhero question
number eight galaxy ronan asks anything
you know about the upcoming show Gotham
yes they have started casting the non
superhero roles it's also going to
feature Bruce Wayne when he's really
young like before the events of Batman
Begins so he'll probably be a teenager
on the show Fox paid Warner Brothers a
dumptruck of money for the rights so
they will be using major characters like
penguin and Catwoman it'll be really
cool I will be doing weekly videos for
it but because the show isn't coming
till the fall I won't start doing videos
for it till the summer you know Rock
Comic Con question number nine Mitch
Panthera asks do you think that Oliver
will fully train Roy and what will his
name be this is going to be in Empire
Strikes Back Luke
Skywalkers situation whereby oliver
slash yoda will start Roy's training but
it took Oliver and even Slade years to
become experts so Roy will complete his
training
you know return to the Jedi style as the
show goes along in future seasons so Roy
isn't gonna become that Jedi level
fighter this season
Oliver's just gonna set him down the
path to becoming red arrow he will be
wearing a red hoodie next week so I
think that they'll do the same thing
they did for Oliver with his name
they'll just call him something like the
red vigilante it won't be exactly like
the comics they'll bend the name a
little bit and they've already called
feeis PD so it definitely won't be that
question number 10 and last one Cal
McKenna asks wouldn't Roy be a good
match against Slade I mean they both
have the serum and once Oliver trains
him they'll be pretty even so a couple
things about this Roy is essentially
untrained and he just got the
superpowers Slade has had a lifetime of
experience as an assassin and he's had
the last six years to get used to the
effects of the mirakuru serum just
because you become super strong and
super fast doesn't mean you
automatically learn to be an expert
fighter so Roy will probably try to take
on Slade and get his ass kicked the
finale will probably be a three on one
fight with Slade versus Oliver Black
Canary and Roy at the same time and
outside chance maybe the flash shows up
with superpowers too so short answer yes
they both have superpowers but Slade is
a much much better fighter thank you so
much for submitting your questions this
is a lot of fun don't worry if I didn't
get to yours I'll be doing arrow Q&A
every week be on the lookout for my
emergency awesome channel update video
that I'll be posting next week I'll be
changing my upload schedule just to make
it easier to do videos like this like
these bonus videos that are a lot of fun
so on the community and American Horror
Story catch up sorry I haven't been able
to upload videos for those this week
doing these super long videos has made
it really hard to get these other videos
up community first number one Troy is
off the show for good now he left
because he's making his own comedy show
that we probably won't get to see until
next year it's called Atlanta and it's
gonna be on FX
number two I'm really liking season 5 so
far the ratings have not been great but
NBC has said that there's still a chance
for a sixth season 3 did you hear when
shanks creamed Nathan Fillion as his
same-sex celebrity crush during the
episode in addition to just being funny
it's also a nod that he's going to be in
next week's episode
it's called analysis of quark based
networking Abed's girlfriend from last
season will be back also she's played by
brie Larson who is amazing so you should
definitely watch that episode
number four because I totally just spent
a few sentences talking about how
amazing next week's episode is going to
be I'm gonna try and move heaven and
earth to do a separate video for it if
you have any specific questions about
this week's community episode just post
them in the comments on American Horror
Story careful for spoilers too because a
lot of big stuff happened in the finale
is next week
number one they implied that fiona is
Gator bait this is just a way for the
writers to say that misty will not be
able to bring her back so I believe that
she's actually dead but we might see her
in the afterlife we did get to see Kathy
Bates and Angela Bassett in Hell so I
think the Fiona will appear just as a
spirit number two to seven Wonders
everyone has to participate remember
that black and white film at the
beginning of the episode it told us that
if you attempt the wonders and you are
not the supreme you will probably die so
what they want us to think is that
everyone who is not the supreme is gonna
die next week and number three supreme
predictions I actually have three
competing theories about the next
supreme my first one is that it really
is Zoe and she and Frank and Kyle will
live out the rest of their days in
magical bliss but really that would be a
bit of a disappointment from a story
standpoint we've spent most of this
season with all the girls saying I'm the
next supreme you know no I'm the next
supreme
well what if none of them are and it's
someone we haven't met yet there's
always a twist it just seems too
convenient for it to be one of them at
this point my third theory is that it
really is Madison and she's just going
to become the next Fiona you know
another terrible supreme that will
destroy the line of Salem think of that
is the apocalypse theory like the worst
possible outcome the show says it all in
the title this is a horror show there's
no happy endings even for Spalding in
that creepy real-life doll baby he has
now
alright so remember big channel update
video coming next week because I'm
almost at a hundred thousand subscribers
you guys all deserve the highest of
fives thank you for being so awesome
right now click here for the era so that
this Q&A is actually based on and click
here for anime club that's gonna post
later tonight thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys a little bit
high fives
you